das ist white crow gedreht von ralf 1
den wir auch in einer der hauptrollen
einer der tragenden rollen des films
beobachten können nämlich als alexander
ivanovic fuß gehen den berühmtesten
ballett lehre des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts und später wirklich
wundervoll
[Musik]
es geht in dem film rudolf nurejew den
vielleicht berühmtesten tänzer des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts blut fließt
allein nein ich lege da nicht die
regierung hole flora das spektakuläre
flucht in den westen erzählt jene tage
und wochen
während derer das damals kirow genannte
mariinsky ballett aus sankt petersburg
eben zu gast weil paris
madame zu den sky wir freuen uns sehr
sie in frankreich begrüßen zu dürfen
dies ist ein historischer moment und
nurejew tritt mit der company auf und
dann entscheidet er sich über die
letzten dramatischen tage dieses gas
spielt aufgrund einer sehr tiefen
innigen freundschaft zu einer jungen
französin der pariser gesellschaft
entscheidet er sich dafür mit ihrer
unterstützung dann in den westen zu
fliegen und diese geschichte erzählt der
schön haben nicht gewusst was er
vorhatte nein mit ihnen also nie über
eine mögliche flucht gesprochen
das thema hat sich als youtube wieder
geben er hat schon so etwas niemals
geredet nein nie also mich begeistert
oleg iveco in der hauptrolle als nur
weil er ist ein fantastischer tänzer und
er sieht natürlich nicht exakt aus wie
könnte das auch sein
aber er hat diesen gesichtsausdruck
diese leichte aufmüpfige ein bisschen
arrogant unheimlich jungen hafte art die
welt sich zu erobern mit einem
selbstbewusstsein das eben aus seinem
können resultiert aber auch mit einer
tiefen demut und bescheidenheit
und einer hinter aber an seine eigene
kunst ob sie sich gedanken darüber
gemacht haben was der zweck des tanzens
ist der zweck ja niemand stellt sich
diese frage
das ist wahr was mir auch sehr gut
gefällt es wir begreifen in diesem film
was tanz eigentlich ist was ballett ist
harte arbeit eigentlich auch ein sport
etwas unglaublich athletisch aber dann
etwas was den menschen und das sieht man
in diesem film wirklich beim großen
publikum aber auch bei der französischen
freundin von nur elf klarer
klar ist das ist den menschen etwas gibt
das ist sie in eine andere welt entführt
in der vollkommen andere gesetze gelten
aber in der unser team ästhetischer sinn
so angeregt wird so dass wir mit gehen
mit dieser bewegung und dass wir auch
das gefühl haben wir können bestimmte
dinge überwinden es liegt freiheit in
der kunst und die entdecken wir auch
wenn wir nur ihre zuschauer sind
man sieht dass es harte arbeit ist eine
zutiefst ernste kunst und dass man damit
sehr viel ausdrücken kann was mit der
sprache vielleicht nicht möglich ist
dass man auch sieht man auch wundervoll
in dem film das ja der tanz uns auch
hilft die musik durch die visualisierung
durch diese gemeinsame aufführung die
musik bässe zu hören besser zu stehen
und all das was tanz kann transportiert
dieser film ganz unaufdringlich ganz
poetisch und sehr realistisch und
deswegen finde ich es ist ein film für
alle
[Applaus]